the Georgians
ooh issues and I sent you that this is
one of the most common questions that's
why I'm recording our people to
appreciate well confront issue of
determinism a Sugo now I'm saying let's
start by saying this I mean the basic
question is I see the basic question
addressed with that if everything is
determined where you want to see both
people
we have three walls we've got to have an
hour
I'm not necessary saying by the way back
up
how come alarms like yesterday I can
even consume that way all I'm saying is
that please look out from the third
frame instead yeah third for any
perspective to logically just break down
keeping out the causal time right so
that they're just you're just a slave to
your driver whatever you're doing you're
just you're just going to be doing
because of what happened before so if
you bring a slamming specific make any
sense because aslam basically a seizure
response you're responsible for your
actions
one school of thought is Port Hardy
terminus to report which is that
everything is you're basically push to
do anything you want to do
there has a very strong argument the
argument is that the manager of the
puzzle - whatever you're doing even
thinking awakens in fact this argument
almost irrefutable
on the other hand is almost another
interview watch which is that we have
intuition
anyone can say whatever they want to do
what self-evident I'm truth
it's self-evident the opportunity
whoa
we're here
I'll say so I do have an interesting one
however there are anomalies for example
if you go to the east you'll see people
that actually if you look for example
bliss they look close enough also
meditative they realize they actually
have no free will they'd like they're
just not only going to realize that but
they actually from direct experience the
same exact direct experience intuition
they see that whatever it is that
whatever it is that they're experiencing
is no actual will marginally it again
of course yeah and I haven't experienced
that myself yeah yes that's right I have
to go through life it could be the same
whoever maybe yeah once a decisions that
we have an intuition for you oh by the
way the justice system is predicated on
this but now it comes into the courtroom
as well
because there was an uninterrupted built
a line of events that led me to kill it
therefore absolve me from the crimes so
every justice system in the whole world
and by the way there's no protest from
this even almost saying that they'll
have a reform of the justice system
where they are so in philosophy there
are three major school for this Islam
one of them is put the hub the terminus
people
the other one is more the libertarian
for flow which is a twist everything is
people and with the delusion of
and in the middle I have the
compatibility for the possible ISM is
where you think there is there is a
reconciliation between your intuitive
free will and the philosophers and
theologians have struggled that would be
the case that everything is determined
and at the same time you have free will
no one has an answer of how that
communicates but the problem is is
logically necessary if you consider the
power of both arguments you intuited
below and beyond interrupter closed
aligned the difference between the
atheist or agnostic determinist and the
muslim of / capitalist and the Muslim
combusted
the opposition is that the problem
the workers at the Muslim position
is that the Muslim will save that
compatibilism is something we don't
understand how it works but the
determiner is a lot
that the poem in Arabic is Arabic and
that is from the wonders of the Jabbar
the compeller that is compelled by bad
the slaves into free will which he
compelled us in the free world
which we seem paradoxical white no it's
not impossible from idiotic therefore
the fact that we have our keys to our
own questions now that whatever your
position is inconsistent it seems like a
contradiction but if that was really the
case the data by Sam Cooke
compatibilism existence which is
visibility logicians and philosophy AG
have accepted that there is a logical
necessity what is a reason for us to
believe that determinism exists at the
same time as what we will now they
accept though they'll say how that
happens we don't know but just because
you don't know something might not get
to the argument from Authority just by
saying to the logicians or
because they believe me to hydrogen
another another say that we shouldn't
put equal weight to our to what we
consider a suit from our intuition vs.
rationality is if we if we look at what
suit from rationality we can get a lot
of screws from it however a lot of times
our senses completely betray us we
cannot derive truth from them all the
time is based on intuition
that's right
if you look at that occupies my restless
take off his Kazuto was I think
therefore I am
if you don't have the intuitive believe
of self-existence which was by the way
refined before him fly and it worked in
Messina hockey there is no doubt there
is existence because you know nature
self
why does he shoot I think therefore I am
yeah
he says that's official position but
have you stand I already kind of like
we found on this this interrogation and
he said what there's no doubt that there
is existence how do we know that
intuition so the point I'm making is if
anything it is going to be one thing
that's gonna overtake the era it's gonna
be intuition on the taking rationally
because it gives us the basis for it and
one versus is exactly in a nutshell are
you saying about argue for for you I'm
saying that this is the point I was
making a beginning will be right this is
not a Muslim specific issue let me say
that more time this is not an Islamic to
issue the issue of the ability of
compatibilist
are so in the ability of can there be a
reconciliation between free will and
determinism atheists have the same
discussions Christians have the same
discussions are Calvinists and Armenian
people they have the same discussions to
each other same discussion
in fact those in Java and Java really
the only discoveries every other day I
said there's only three well I know
determinism and the Sunda which is the
middle path which is that if there is a
compatible now these three school before
has been represented not only in Western
philosophy but what I'm saying to you is
that if you want to be the easiest would
have not you're not gonna escape this
disagreement so you can run away from
Islam and think that the problem of
determinism will have probably
determination of free will versus
determinism is going to be resolved by
you vertically the one saying you
wherever you run and wherever you go
this problem will persist because it's
one of the highest
yes this gives us our fun come to us and
tells us look there are limits to
understanding you're not good enough now
if there is how how is it the case that
free will
connects with determinism what you
should know is that both of those things
are and most logically guaranteed and
intuitively granted in the case of
pre-work so for that reason how it is
really just about some beginner which
and we live this so quick paradoxes
every day bro come on in quantum
mechanics that you can have things I
have no courses you can have two hot
buttons in the same place at same time
the laws of logic are basically
destroyed by quantum mechanics but we
enjoy those
these pretextual contradictions
these are few contradictions these
glaring these conspicuous paradoxes cool
we enjoy them because we know that both
of these things
they must be a reason that we don't know
here otherwise we would have canceled
Ofcom to mechanics who would have come
to the spot recites okay so then you're
basically saying that Queen Azshara I'm
sorry are you saying that because
because of quantum mechanics is a very
very accurately using a phrase of
mathematical operation up to like seven
decimal places musics for it this way
like as I've even while you talk a
hundred metric
you can't connect and heatedly doesn't
reduces I was also gonna comment on
scientists are full to enjoy the
communication accessible is that if
something appears to be a consolation
but you know there's a reason why I
believe in tradition and the Front's
mechanics ym sites we love got no reason
so we all say up because we don't know
you get a rejection what we say is that
we don't know what it was a how out
there which is going to be maybe our
troubled that's right
so whatever has been adjusted is
we're learning punch mechanic material
as I've just been into filmmaking though
there is something that that we don't
know
thank you mentioned so I clearly do that
but then when I was going to say though
before your point before was that
whenever you say rationality is part of
our intuition I completely agree with
however saying for example that I did
that I lifted this water boat because I
had the three well
what I'm saying is this because I lifted
a flurbot I'm what I'm getting from
using I lifted this because of my and
have an intuitive sense that I have free
will so I'm lifting right
argument I'm saying is that because I
can actually place a third party
observer
and I just mean consistent
or the operator usually is one of the
kindest to be incorrect friggin duck
my permanent position makes more sense
you can have that position outside of
this country's understand you will never
be able to escape but those who say what
if everything is written and outcomes we
have removed I say to them
atheists and agnostics you can push a
believer in Israel and everything is
determined the only difference between
me and you is that you guys believe that
rules uninterrupted for the wine and we
say is Allah in fact what we say is more
logical to go first
you guys just went from one thing to
another you're just changing the jargon
from from from religious to consult for
what the concepts are exactly the same
I will never I cannot actually it shows
you that Islamic knowledge this
fundamental philosophical question and
it was the only religion to acknowledge
it and you
give us answers which might not be
something that you other son is highly
efficient unaccounted but I wish you
gave some reference to the sample
dimensional thing about determinism